records in the state of Virginia here he
goes
and he's putting on the handle
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
crap CJ going to shaking one good job
man
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have witnessed a
star being born tonight let's stop it a
star has been born tonight a star a star
like an NBA star an NBA star has been
born tonight his name will be realm
throughout Here Comes McClung
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
over 50.
so you see how everyone's standing
including us
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the NBA
welcome to the NBA did you see Jonathan
Majors
his excitement yeah yeah this is a major
movie star reacting like that worry
about the guy holding the other guy some
boy he gonna go down
that's a 50. uh I got to see if he hit
the tobacco
champion
this is what you guys need to know look
at the NBA Ballers the All-Star
All-Stars how they are reacting to it